Yeah, so
one thing that'll be really helpful for
this project is using the developer
tools provided to you by Chrome.
In our particular,
the JavaScript console be really,
really useful in giving
you information on
what still isn't being defined or
what you still need to call.
And make sure you make use
of the console.log function.
So I've noted things on my local host,
I've, there you go,
see I have two errors already.
I enter these as not defined and
then you know player is not defined.
So basically I have this error here.
I'm like okay, well where,
how do i go and look into this error?
Well, Google Tools has some
awesome tool sets for you and
you can just like really expand
the error, it's going to tell you.
>> Exactly.
>> In your stack.
So basically I am going in.
>> First thing is, on the right side,
it tells you the finding.
>> The founding or the line numbers?
>> Line number.
>> Line numbers, yes, exactly.
>> And essentially you can go to that
line number, go to the first error.
Also the files come with lots of
comments that explain what you
need to do.
>> Yeah.
>> What your code should look like.
>> Exactly.
>> And that's a good start,
give it a try.
I really recommend, I mean personally,
I don't like to go look for
an answer before I try it.
>> Yeah, try it.
Just be like a detective or
be there's a picture, like you could
be a detective or could be a dare devil,
like you're the coding dare devil,
you just dive straight in,
try to break things up.
>> Be at three year old
>> Exactly.
>> Yes tha's what they do.
>> Yeah, when you have a three year old.
Right?
Six.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> So I mean,
yeah, be that daring person and try to
explore and purposely break things.
So I'm exploring,
I'm breaking things right now.
>> Absolutely.
>> I'm going to click on engine.js on
line number 94.
So the engine will say okay, I'm going
to do function of the entities and
says are enemies for each enemy.
> Exactly
>> And
then it says on [CROSSTALK] references
our enemies is not defined.
I'm not define myself all enemies.
>> Go ahead define all enemies.
>> Let's just go define all enemies and
then go through the code.
If you look through
the code a little more you
will find that all
enemies will be in f.js.
Here, now there it goes, see here's
instructions now instantiate your
objects place all enemy objects
in a raid called all enemies.
>> There you go.
>> Now why don't i just
to create something
in my code that says for
all enemies equals that.
>> See what happens.
Can I save this?
No I don't think I can save this.
If you run suggest you'll
get some more errors.
And then you need to find out okay,
what's next step.
>> What's the next step?
>> What's the next step, error.
I need to I'll give you a hint.
I actually have nothing in all enemies
because I was supposed to have some
sort of like new enemy I think.
New enemy, maybe new enemy,
now I instantiate it.
Actually in your js course,
I create a new object by putting new.
So okay, save that and
see what else writes.
Now handle these errors
one step at a time, and
just think of errors as bread crumbs,
they are clues to what you need to do.
>> Absolutely.